[Music]
can we watch the dominatrix thing now
yeah yeah let's watch this guy get
kicked on the nuts you give Princeton to
everyone to kick you in the nuts might
get that far all right do you convince
me yes all right
hold it hold it hold it
how was that burning
burning she's Burns Burns burning I
didn't hear that I was just more focused
on her slapping his back like a coach
that's what I'm saying come on it's okay
come on you'll get through this one come
on now you ever seen those old videos of
martial arts specifically dim mock where
they put on like it's just pressure
points they can put you out yeah it
looks like one of those demonstrations
like yeah now watch this and one kick
one point of the toe
I'm gonna take him out
boom kick some of the nuts all right all
right
Breeze
Montana he's good burning burning
I like he's like not down yeah he's like
actually that I'm good yeah I thought
I'd like this but yeah it kind of sucks
burning burning
somebody else
2V1 defending the bomb site
bro that sounded like dropping groceries
on concrete oh my God that's dude that's
the sound your doordasher makes when
they throw your [__] Popeyes at your
front door man let's run that back run
that back listen to this sound
[Laughter]
holy [__] now this dominatrix uh she's
just suited with some good old you know
like platforms yeah two inch platforms
three-inch platforms so that's foot on
[__]
that that was an MMA strike man oh my
God oh my god dude
oh my God
burning burning I'm grabbing my balls
watch this I know right I feel like
nauseous a little bit yeah
oh this is great spits in his face
yeah I don't think he likes that he's
like not down
there you go just that one she kicked
him in the ribs yes Swift kicked to the
ribs he's like oh I didn't yeah he's
like hold on now what parking lot is
this foreign
get those little nuts please me next
I love everything about this clip can I
pay for your breakfast goddess I want to
see this take a weird turn
with some Trend out you like royuted
yoked guy just walks out like eyes
pinned open he's like me now he just but
it's like um
it's like a withstanding it thing oh
yeah okay it's an endurance thing so
like she's kicking him in the nuts and
yeah now it's a game of he can't be
dominated he consents to everything but
none of it works yeah yeah yeah
so this could be a new like
I know I guess like people that are like
fans of you know like huberman and Joe
Rogan and stuff yeah sort of like right
leaning like uh morning routine like
Optimal Human Performance people sure
are like anti-sunglasses now
um this is something that is new I guess
it's a new development okay like they
make fun of people that wear sunglasses
because I guess like sun on your corneas
is
not a bad thing or something like that
right so they're like this is another
thing that the left like is is like you
know making you do because yeah they're
turning you gay yeah yeah exactly
so this could be a new thing that they
do
is they're all into like getting kicked
as many times in the nuts as possible
because they're like David Goggins pulls
up on a dominatrix on exactly who's
going
who's Good's nuts yeah yeah yeah yeah he
stands there he gets kicked in the balls
a hundred times and then all the world
record yeah and then all the um optimal
human podcasts get on and they go
it's like huberman
can I get the mood lighting you know
it's funny uh dominatrix isn't a thing
you know people like to present it as
this sort of genre of
pornography or sex but it's just a weak
mind
for example I train my body for a good
three months
and I performed a study a case study on
my own I met up with over a hundred
dominatrix in a parking lot
and I stood there in a small Speedo
to see if they could humiliate me I let
each of them kick me in the balls 30
times you know what I found out getting
kicked in the nuts is healthy
I found that the human body can't
withstand as several kicks to the groin
and we only think we can't get kicked in
the nuts because we've been conditioned
to
mentally protect our nerves there when
you look back and you look at human
development
Homo Sapien uh cavemen they used to
actually slam their nuts on rocks
it was it was an atonement it was a it
was a thing of attrition it was a way to
combat the elements and in fact it was a
way to attract a mate
they would actually smash their nuts
with a hard rock to show the women in
the tribe that they were the strongest
one
so
if you if you engage in in dominatrix
Behavior or if you enjoy being dominated
I would suggest to you
that you
maybe take a look at the programming
you're receiving and maybe take a step
outside of what you you're normally told
and realize the full capacity of your
nutsack another fun side effect my [__]
and balls are unrecognizable
fully just mutilated it's a swollen mess
down there
I can't pee anymore can't pee I can't
come
but you don't you don't need those
things those are for the week because if
you look at our ancestors what we had
found is that they only came once
just one come
they made one child and they never came
again at one come
singular come we've conditioned
ourselves to think we need to come a lot
but in fact you only need to come once
yeah exactly regular there you go yeah
that's it yeah
I got kicked in the balls one thousand
times
so so they're they're against big
sunglasses never look at any lights so
bright that it's painful look at and of
course blinking is okay oh blinking's
okay don't wear sunglasses for number
one provided you can do that safely
oh Mr huberman uh performing the this oh
yeah this is the morning routine [__] so
maybe that's what it is just don't wear
sunglasses in the morning because you
need
sun exposure oh I've seen him say this
in order to like be fully happy or
whatever but actually I kind of buy I
think it's funnier to misrepresent his
point and start a start a conspiracy
yeah I think so too and so people can
tweet a human and say so you're the one
that thinks sunglasses turn you
homosexual okay dude okay yeah